here we are at the wired party taking a
break from the show floor at CES 2012
man CES is like bringing an entire city
into the Las Vegas Convention Center
something like 140,000 people are
attending this year and each company
that's showcasing their products has to
build these elaborate boots to show off
their products some of these places
build multi-story structures there's
walls of 3d TVs there's rooms for
demoing products it's crazy I love
getting to play with the new products
that are coming out like the HTC Titan
to and the Nokia Lumia 900 and I also
enjoy getting to meet all my colleagues
um other journalists all around the
world that maybe I talked with on
Twitter all the time and now I get to
meet them in person but now i think i'm
going to go dance
we're here at the wired party taking a
step back to see what we've seen on the
show floor this week at the Consumer
Electronics Show now 2011 was an
interesting year for 3d technology
especially as it pertains to televisions
but 2012 I think is going to be a
make-or-break here now personally I like
3d technology I think it really pops I
think it's very dynamic for the content
especially for sports and other movies
but it's it's reassuring to see that the
tech manufacturers are not backing away
they're actually super committed to 3d
and you see that being adopted into
super high-end screens such as those
with oled and ultra definition
resolution so while there were some
strides made in 2011-2012 is definitely
going to have to see a lot more progress
in order for 3d technology to stick
around
i'm at the wired party at CES 2012 and
it's time to talk about trends so
tablets were big trend developing at the
show this year we have 7-inch tablets
7.7 inch tablets honeycomb tablets Ice
Cream Sandwich tablets these are all
versions of Android you have tablets
that are about to become ice cream
sandwich we have tablets running nvidia
tegra 3 quad-core processors so
everyone's coming out with a different
kind of tablet that's meant to compete
directly with the apple ipad of course
but also the kindle fire and the prices
are getting much lower so tablets were
sort of disappointing last year but CES
is giving it another big shot for 2012
so that's tablets also very interesting
fitness gear and so everyone's coming
out with some kind of device that could
help you track how many stairs you're
climbing how many miles you're walking
there's even a device that we checked
out last night you attach it to your
left forearm it can tell you how many
calories you've burned and it could even
you could leave it on overnight so
really cool stuff coming out in the
fitness space there's TVs the big o LED
LG TV awesome great picture quality of
course 3d TVs are back as well can't
wait to get out there for one more day
check out more and finish up a great CES
i'm here at the wired party taking a
break from the CES show floor pretty
much everything that we've seen so far
this year is what we expected to see
something that was a little bit
unexpected is that we anticipated there
were going to be more android phones and
tablets shipping with the new version of
android that just came out called ice
cream sandwich well there are a lot of
phones and tablets we're running Android
most of them are running the older
versions and the people that have been
showing them to us have told us that
they're going to update the new phones
and tablets with ice cream sandwich in
the coming months so that was a little
bit unexpected the other thing that I've
seen that I've been really impressed
with are all of the cameras and all the
action in all the different camera
categories from point2 shoots to smaller
body cameras with interchangeable lenses
to brand-new DSLRs seen some really
exciting stuff from all the big names
like Nikon and Canon and fujifilm and
we're really hoping to see those cameras
come out soon because it looks like
they're going to be really big hit with
consumers I suppose there's also some
buzz around Windows Phone and Windows 8
tablets but from what we've seen there's
not a whole lot but the devices we have
seen are pretty strong even so they're
not going to come out for a few more
months so we're going to sort of weight
to pass judgment on that but there is a
lot of buzz around windows on mobiles
which is a big change over previous
years so that's my take and if you'll
excuse me I gotta go back to work hey
guys i'm here at the wired after party
after a long long week at CES and to be
honest has been kind of boring microsoft
was supposed to blow it out of the water
this year with their last keynote and i
almost fell asleep in the middle of the
conference trying to write something up
Steve Ballmer the CEO is obviously
supposed to be crazy as usual and he
didn't really talk about anything there
were no new products the one person the
one company that did surprise me was
Nokia the company that I had there
our dumb phone in high school in my
backpack is now actually coming out with
a whole line of new smartphones to take
on Apple and Google and Android and you
know I don't know if they could do it
but it made me it made me excited to see
that at least someone is trying to take
on the big tech titans other than that I
know super cool innovations a lot of
stupid tablets that can go underwater
could probably get shot with one of them
and stop a bullet although I wouldn't
try that I was not willing to be a
tester and a whole lot of no sleep and
dirty bathrooms and and terrible food on
the show floor so I can't wait till next
year but as for me I'm going to go home
and get a heck of a lot of sleep